we're asked to figure out what is
one-seventh divided by four and they
help us out with this diagram we have a
whole divided into seven equal sections
each of those is a seventh and we have
one of those sevenths filled in so this
is one seventh right over here and then
they divide it into four equal sections
in fact they divide all of the sevens
into four equal sections and so
one-seventh which is this whole green
bar divided by four well that would be
this
fraction of the whole that is in a
question mark so can you pause this
video and figure out what fraction of
the whole is this question mark
well when we divided the first 7th into
4 equal sections we also divided all of
the sevenths into four equal sections
and so now the entire hole is 28 equal
sections because you have a four by
seven grid you have one two three four
rows and you still have your seven
columns and you could count them 7 14 21
and so 1 7 divided by 4 is going to be
one of these 28 sections so this right
over here is 1 over 28 so this is 1
28th
let's do another example
we're told use the number line below to
help visualize one-fifth
being divided by three
so when as we go from zero to one on the
number line you could divide into five
equal sections where that's one-fifth
two-fifths three-fifths four-fifths and
of course five-fifths is equal to one
but we want one-fifth divided by three
so we took the section from zero to
one-fifth and we divided into three
equal sections and so the first of those
sections this one right over here that
would be
one-fifth divided by three so what is
this going to be equal to pause this
video again and see if you can figure
that out
well the key realization is is when we
divided each of the fifths into three
more equal sections we can now think of
each of these steps as a 15th because
now we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 equal sections between 0 and 1.
and where did that 15 come from well we
had 5 equal sections and then we split
each of those 5 into 3 more equal
sections so 5 times 3 is 15. so this
right over here is 1 15 this is 2 15.
this is 3 15 which is equivalent to
one-fifth and we could keep going on and
on and on but the key realization here
is if i take that first one-fifth and if
i divide into three equal sections and i
go only as far as that first of the
three equal sections that is going to be
one fifteenth
one fifteenth and we are done